[Musik]
am morgen des 20 august 1885 er schlägt
anna-maria ihren mann mit einer axt
[Musik]
im keller dateien sees fitte liegen
werkzeuge und holz geschirr kreuz und
quer herum überall ist blut
unter einem brett findet die polizei
eine axt
daneben liegt das notizbuch von johnny
anna marias ehemann
[Musik]
auch das notizbuch ist voller blut
sie war eher eine wie ein mann schon
ihre stimme war die eines mannes
viele hatten angst wenn sie sprach über
100 jahre nach anna marias tat fahren
wir zum ort des geschehens zu mainz
salva braunau im bündnerischen zum fixer
teil wir wollen ergründen warum er
schlug ohne maria ihren mann
[Musik]
in diesem stall verbringt anna-maria die
letzte nacht neben ihrem mann gleich
nebenan liegt die hütte in der sie john
dalli schlug diese ist längst verfolgt
über dem tatort wächst gras
die kann das portal sollen von ihrem
neuen sees pardatscher ausgesehen haben
wie ohne maria das haus durch das
hintere fenster verließ das muss wohl
nach der tat gewesen sein
nach der tat fand anna maria nach hause
zwei stunden sind es bis ins dorf rabius
sie begegnet mehreren leuten
sie fragten sie wo ihr mann sei die
schau in kaffee dazu den titel ein sie
hatte vorgehabt ihn über die brücke zu
werfen als wäre ihr herunter gefallen
sie wollte den mord kaschieren
hin zu rein erzählte mir einen mann vor
ein paar jahren seine großmutter habe
gesehen wie die leiche dieses john kerry
transportiert worden sei
aus dem mist wagen hätten beschlagene
schule heraus grad
als die leiche des 42-jährigen jonnier
die nach hause gebracht wird ist es
dunkel anna maria ward zwei tage und
zwei nächte neben ihrem mann sie betet
und begleitet ihn auf den friedhof nach
dem begräbnis gesteht sie die tat
danach wird die junge täterin verhaftet
und in disentis eingesperrt sie
wiederholt ihr geständnis vor dem
kreisgericht sie macht geltend ihr mann
habe seit zwei wochen nicht mehr zu
hause übernachtet am letzten abend sei
er lange in der mitte der stiefmutter
gewesen bis um zehn uhr abends
sie habe die ganze nacht nicht schlafen
können und sei am morgen sehr verwirrt
gewesen in diesem zustand habe sie dann
ihren mann getötet
sie sei oft wütend auf ihn gewesen aber
mordgedanken habe sie nie gehabt
[Musik]
eine woche nach der tat wird anna maria
von disentis nach chur überführt ans
kantonsgericht
alles geht sehr schnell
sie kann sich nicht einmal mehr von
ihrer familie verabschieden von ihrem
kind ihrer schwester ihrem auge
vorab muss sieht sie ein letztes mal
dass ein fixer tal den ort wo sie ihren
mann tötete sieht die kirche mit dem
friedhof vor ihrer eltern begraben sind
er ist wenige monate zuvor hat sie den
vater begraben die mutter starb vor
vielen jahren als anna maria noch ein
kind war
[Applaus]
in chur im gefängnis sennhof kommt sie
in untersuchungshaft
sie ist 21 jahre alt sie hat einen bogen
von 13 monaten und erwartet ein zweites
kind
die verhöre im sennhof dauern sechs
monate einen verteidiger bekommt sie
während der ganzen strafuntersuchung
nicht
einen verteidiger bekommt sie erst eine
woche vor der gerichtsverhandlung
[Musik]
damals ist das üblich ziehen und marc
sie also hat ein herrscht nach abschluss
von der untersuchung
einbezogen und das hat man bewusst so
gemacht will man hat eigentlich welle
dass die angeschuldigte das
stimmt was sie gemacht hat dass sie also
wir eigentlich der staatsanwaltschaft
schon alles aber wie es mit liefert und
daher natürlich ein verteidiger er
gestört also schau immer an ma oder
männer wo sie befragen
frauen rauchen während der ganzen
untersucht und übrigens auch vor gericht
muss sich also jetzt das brutale die
ausdrucke immer der männer ausgeliefert
die akten des falls anna-maria befinden
sich im staatsarchiv des kantons
graubünden
armin vinzens war bis vor wenigen jahren
erster staatsanwalt im kanton graubünden
er stammt wie anna maria aus der bündner
oberland und kennt die verhältnisse dort
sehr gut er hat den fall für uns
studiert und beurteilt die arbeit seiner
amtskollegen aus heutiger sicht
in den akten befinden sich skizzen des
tatorts verhörprotokolle verschiedene
zeugenaussagen und das notizbuch von
john lee
die blutspuren sind bis heute zu
erkennen
das urteil besteht aus gerade mal fünf
handgeschriebenen seiten der fall schien
also klar gewesen zu sein
wenn man auch tiger leser dort hat sich
das stehe im oberland der bewohner der
sind
emotionen die würden sie am liebsten auf
der stelle
an frau headhunter an
obama umzubringen
diabolisch sei berichtet
der mainz es im sumpf fixer teil rechts
im bild sieht man das kurhotel wald
häusern es wurde etwa 20 jahre nach der
tat gebaut anna maria und ihr mann
hatten auf dem mars einen stall und eine
hütte in unmittelbarer nähe wohnte auch
anna marias stiefmutter ganz hinten am
waldrand ist die hütte zu erkennen in
der anna maria ihren mann erschlug dass
ich an rekonstruktion vom tatort und der
umgebung
und da sich der stahl motoren reglement
die wedges die nacht verbracht und
winter rechts ist
eindeutig sie
moderiere marschlager hat und dadurch
die hütte vor der stiefmutter
der letzte morgen ungefähr so abgrund
vor der nackten das einem reh als ich
aufgestanden ist relativ frühe für den
morgen kocht
etwa schickt den von amri aber zur
stiefmutter oder aber
und seit sie müssen sich um das tier
holen der auto offenbar krank oder vom
tisch sie macht das grund
druckfrisch im keller tour küssen sache
notiere sicher
erbschaft erteilt worden ich sie wird
verrückt dass er jetzt die sache macht
und gardinen
sitzt immer noch mit dem rocker ihrer zu
erklärt sie
knackt die achsen schlag mit der axt
also der mieter mit der spitze oder mit
dem rocker ihm der kopf mehrmals die
seite können sich nicht erinnern wie oft
sie hat angst er könnte die angriffe der
umschlag zum hals sagt sie
wieviel transitwege sie meint ich
dreimal der arzt seine 712 schräg sie
zwei wochen nach der tat wird anna maria
im sennhof chor zum ersten mal verhört
ich heiße anna maria und wurde in rabius
geboren nachdem ich aus der schule kam
half ich meinem vater und meiner
stiefmutter bei der feldarbeit
ein jahr bevor ich meinen mann heiratete
trafen wir uns eines tages in einem berg
gut ich war damals noch ganz unerfahren
wir führten miteinander den beischlaf
aus es war dies das einzige mal dass ich
mich mit ihnen fleischlich abgegeben
habe
zwei monate bevor das kind zur welt kam
teilte ihm mit dass ich schwanger sei
und zwar von ihm
darauf wurde ich mehrere male zum
pfarrer gerufen er sagte wenn ihr auch
verfehlt habt so dürfte auch heiraten
ich habe meinen mann geheiratet ohne
irgendwelche liebe zu ihm damit das
geschwätz der leute aufhören
sie muss nicht unattraktiv sie
sich bildungsmäßig wie es damals hieß
geht primarschul gemacht und analyse vom
land helfen sie wird auch grob
eigentlich beschrieben was damals
eigentlich waschen die nicht unüblich
dass man einfach an gar nicht
miteinander
sie hätte aber doch irgendwie
selbstbewusst ca sie wehrt sich
eigentlich gegen die höhe ragt sie will
nicht sie kann
sich offenbar um das gefühl
dass das kind jetzt geboren wird sondern
der andere teil wird deshalb
eine wo eigentlich schock wüssten
was sie will in rabius leben noch einige
personen die anna maria gekannt haben
besonders die frauen haben sich über den
fall gedanken gemacht
wir sprachen schon mit meiner darüber
sie sagte immer man hat ihr unrecht
getan sie sind selbst schuld dass es so
weit gekommen ist
sie habe ihn heiraten müssen und sie
habe nicht gewollt ob sie sich auf
diesem seien sehr in die haare geraten
sind sie brachte ihn jedenfalls um
[Musik]
frauen mit unehelichen kindern wurden
schlecht behandelt
ich weiß von einer frau die sich in der
kirche nicht neben die anderen frauen
setzen durfte
[Musik]
das war ein enormes vergehen ich weiß
von familien die ihre töchter aus dem
haus sagt solche fälle gab es viele im
dorf sie wurden verstoßen
wenn eine frau vor der heirat schwanger
wurde konnte sie sich gleich begraben
lassen inzwischen hat sich das gott sei
dank gebessert
gott sei dank
man hätte mit dem düsen mit der hütte
mit allen möglichen funktionen
haben wir die allod versucht
disziplinieren damit der geburt
rechtwidrig
besonderes gewicht liegt die pfarrer auf
das sechste gebot und auf die sexualität
das sechste gebot ich dass ich sie wo
neben dem die andere völlig
bedeutungslos sie sind real der sechste
gebot denn die strafe nur stars wo du
musst du wieder gutmachen was lang
erlebt wenn diese theorie muss sie muss
sich eigentlich ständig und interessant
wie das mobil wird jetzt den fahrer
nicht vorweisen
das ist üblich sie
ungewollte schwangerschaften sind damals
häufig sie und tut lösung ist eigentlich
entweder führt sie in dem fall hatte der
fahrer die beide dazu gedrängt oder sich
die frau ihr verstoßen worden ist sozial
geächtet wurde und man muss auch sehen
dass ihr der damalige zig wald viel
präsenter sich die heime wie auch im
öffentlichen raum die ltte hat sich mit
schleck wird es gibt auch mutiger
relativ als hütte und das ist also
situation wo diana maria ein reines
praxis die hat ihm sicherlich das
schönste aber kaum
in der untersuchungshaft verliert
anna-maria ihr kind sie war im fünften
monat schwanger das protokoll hält
lakonisch fest die frühgeburt habe
keinerlei schlimme folgen zurückgelassen
nach der vereidigung wohnten mein mann
und ich zusammen mit der ganzen familie
unter einem dach in rabius er war sehr
aufbrausend und geizig und machte mir
ständig vorwürfe wegen des kindes
wenn ich auch hier und da glaubte grund
zu haben aufzubegehren
so fand ich es für mich besser zu
schweigen
geschlechtlichen umgang hatten wir sehr
selten miteinander und es war immer eher
der denselben wollte
wenn der streit hatten ging er immer zu
meiner stiefmutter und erzählte ihr
alles nach diesen besuchen war er noch
größer als sonst
zu auseinandersetzungen er machte ihre
vorwürfe
scheint das ja
wort du warst grund sowie dass er sie
als [ __ ] bezeichnet
dem kind zeit fuhren kind und tut sie
beleidige bloß stellen sie sich auch die
dreifache frau xia das heißt auch
vereine das sieht sich sogar relativ
grob sie
sogar das kind das ich auch aktenkundig
und
irgendwo heißt denn in der nackte
maschine fotos ideen für ihre sie hat
immer schwierig das einfach aber
geschockt
[Musik]
anna-maria lebte in einem doppelhaus in
rabius in der einen hälfte wohnte ihre
stiefmutter zusammen mit dem stiefbruder
in der anderen anna maria zusammen mit
mann und sohn der schwester und dem
onkel das sagen hatten wie im
erzkatholischen mit jener jahre üblich
die männer
die frauen hatten nichts zu sagen sie
waren wie sklavinnen was der mann befall
musste getan werden
die frauen trugen ein schweres kreuz ich
habe gehört wie frauen sagten man konnte
nicht auseinandergehen wie sie das heute
tun wegen jeder kleinigkeit
einige tage vor der tat kommt es zu
heftigen auseinandersetzungen zwischen
anna marias mann und ihrem onkel es geht
um erfragen
anna-maria versucht zu schlichten ihr
mann verlässt darauf wütend das haus von
da an schläft er im stall
spitzig mehr zur immer wieder die stink
3 in dem ruf eine verhältnis
verschiedene interesse
an ganz und schlechte atmosphäre xxi das
geht sich klar um
was anna maria besonders verletzt ist
der umstand dass ihr mann alles der
stiefmutter weitererzählt diese so anna
maria habe ihm recht gegeben und ständig
über ihre familie geschimpft vor allem
aber über sie
das gefühl dass ich schwer drunter geht
umso mehr als sie im dritten monat
schwangere sich wieder normal und durch
das natürlich sehr empfindlich oder
empfindlichkeit müsse trotzdem mit dem
tritt dritte monat alter hut und in dem
zustand welt geschaffen und immer wieder
die er stritt 3 und muss ein anderer
setzt
kurz nach unserem großen streit gingen
mein mann mein onkel meine schwester und
ich für zwei tage im einsatz zum heulen
am zweiten tage kam gegen abend ein hirt
von der alb runter und teilte uns mit
dass wir dort ein krankes kind hätten
mein mann solle am nächsten tag kommen
um es zu holen
meine stiefmutter hatte in der nähe des
unsrigen ebenfalls ein mainzer
deswegen gehe ich am abend nicht mit
meiner schwester und dem onkel heim ich
wollte zusammenkünfte meines mannes mit
der stiefmutter verhindern
sie schlaf denn die nacht wieder mit ihm
im stall
geschlechtlich 1 nicht mehr miteinander
die zwei die nacht hat das wehr denn die
die nacht fordert ich gott der wieder zu
stiefmutter blieb lange zieht de leit
sich auf zwei redet mit sie schwach aber
das wird nicht geredet miteinander
[Applaus]
am morgen stand ich noch vor
tagesanbruch auf mein mann erhob sich
ebenfalls gleich nach mir vom lager ich
bereitete das frühstück bestehend aus
kaffee und polenta
während dem frühstück haben wir
miteinander gesprochen
wenn auch nicht in einem
freundschaftlichen ton
[Musik]
sie
demontierten
grünen schlafen sie
schlafe ich voller gedanken was soll ich
jetzt machen was war
das doch nur mal wieder
nach dem frühstück begab sich mein mann
in den keller
dort saß er auf irgendeinen kübel
und machte aufzeichnungen
[Musik]
da ich bereits wild war dass er die zeit
damit verlor werkzeuge und geräte
aufzulisten statt auf die alb zu gehen
begab ich mich in den keller nahm die
axt die hinter ihm lag der griff sie mit
beiden händen und schlug damit auf den
hinterkopf
er fiel sofort neben den trog nieder
ich versetze ihn noch ein paar streicher
aus angst dass wenn er auf die füße käme
er mich selber töten könnte
plötzlich hörte ich jemanden ausrufen
herr jesus was geht da drinnen vor ich
warf die aqsiq schloss den keller ab und
suchte das freie in dem ich unter dem
dach hinter der hütte hinaus koch damit
mich meine stiefmutter nicht sehe
dann nahm ich den waldweg und ging
direkt nach hause ohne mich auf dem weg
aufzuhalten
[Musik]
die folgenden tage habe ich kaum
gegessen und geschlafen
ich wusste nicht was ich tat und
wo ich stand
[Musik]
aufgrund vor dem wc schilde wenigstens
am anfang immer das gefühl
im affekt sie irgendwo bereits die axt
auf die tour zum im schloss sich das
findet sie die axt zur felge wie es ist
wird wegen dem was schon früh gefallen
ist dir verschiedene
auseinandersetzungen und jetzt der
dritte und chinas als die erbschaft pc
ist die gräber und dennoch das gehässige
die tour so sagt sie und es spricht
einiges sind richtig deutsch lag
einen monat nach der tat werden im hotel
weniger bad unweit des tatortes zeugen
befragt es kommt zu einer folgenschweren
aussage ein 12 jähriger hirte sagt aus
es stimme nicht dass er anna maria am
abend vor der tat mitgeteilt habe ihr
mann müsse auf die alb kommen wo man
krankes kind zu holen
für den untersuchungsrichter heißt dass
anna-maria hat ihren mann im einsatz
festgehalten um ihn zu töten
zwei kreuze die unterschrift des hirten
machen aus anna maria eine mörderin
für die untersuchung geführt hätte ich
das natürlich sofort an hinwies sie das
könnte plan wie sie dass ich alles der
forschung zum die tat begonnen sie
selber zu dem eigentlich immer sein dass
es mit dem überhaupt nützt uhr ich habe
lediglich weller dass er wie mir blieb
und irgendein grund hanni museums segen
der mitte der nacht mit meer verbringt
nicht aber zu der das stück wurde mir
ist im bett ohne high kommt an ideen
das hat er ist sehr sportlich bitte bei
frau hanni an die möglichkeit denkt die
quinten umbringen also entweder der
vorläufe mit dem kind oder aller falls
ihn umbringen
[Musik]
anna marias motive und sie entlastende
aussagen werden vom untersuchungsrichter
nicht berücksichtigt so gibt etwa die
stiefmutter ungefragt zu protokoll john
dee sei am abend nicht bei ihr in der
hütte gewesen bloß vor der hütte ihr
eigener sohn anna marias halbbruder sagt
genau das gegenteil doch derlei
gegensätzliche aussagen interessieren
den untersuchungsrichter so wenig wie
die frage ob zwischen john kerry und
anna marias stiefmutter ein verhältnis
bestand
um gaby köster ist das vielleicht
verständlich dass ich mit einer frau
nord problem aufgestaut hat aber es
wirkt da nur der einzelne momente im
moment kurz bevor sie getötet hat ist
sie den ruf recht sie haben stritt
miteinander hat sie muss der emotion
muss erkannt hat dann ist es ein fall wo
richtig auf weg dort wo milder bestraft
wird und im gegenteil wenn vorher planig
wenn sie dann mal nicht klappt hat die
dfs den luftraum und ihn dann vorhinein
geplant mit einer axt hat dann spricht
das für besonders große schuld also für
schwer wiegen die dort
erst eine woche vor dem prozess bekommt
anna maria einen verteidiger außerdem
erklärt ein arzt sie nach einer kurzen
untersuchung für gesund und somit
schuldfähig
am fünften und sechsten märz 1886 wird
die täterin vor gericht geführt der
gerichtsschreiber macht diese
zeichnungen von ihr
laut presseberichten ist der
gerichtssaal überfüllt auch aus radios
sind zahlreiche leute nach kuh angereist
die angeklagte antwortet klar und
bestimmt von zeit zu zeit so die presse
erstickten tränen ihre stimme und
zuweilen blitzte es unheimlich aus den
jugendlichen augen und verzerrte sich
seltsam das antlitz der anleger plädiert
auf mord der verteidiger auf totschlag
wenn man die geschichte
ganz distanzierter perspektiven alex
eben nicht dass das eine affekthandlung
sie war
ich habe auf der anderen seite ganz
wichtig zu betonen dass eigentlich
staatsanwaltschaft bewiesen muss dass
sie mit vor bedacht ermordet hat uns
gericht muss zur überzeugung dass das
wifu trabis stadt dass sie das mit vor
bedacht gemacht hat das ist bewies
lauscht und zu sturz in dubio pro reo er
vom milderes straftatbestand ausgegangen
werden und da hat man damals wohl über
die ursachen der untersuchungsphase hat
man das resultat der bislich vorgespurt
wo es natürlich auch sehe das ist
tatsache dass die
bevölkerung natürlich straße ging das
ist ja verrückt das heißt im urteil sie
hat nicht nur der eigene mann braucht
brutal sondern sie hat auch der
kinder also die kinder rain demo gezockt
ich vaterlos gemacht und auch das kind
das sie unter ihrem herzen trug auch das
heck raafat omega
und das ist natürlich
wenn man das versucht die damalige zieht
das damalige denke völlig nicht
emanzipierte frau monique sega hat macht
deshalb bis hätten's maschine auch noch
mit mühe kam zu mir das als totschlag
begründe das kantonsgericht kommt zum
urteil es handle sich um einen lange und
gut vorbereiteten mord und verurteilt
anna-maria zu 25 jahren zuchthaus
am tag der verurteilung kommt es zu
einer merkwürdigen koinzidenz
in rabius brennen das schulhaus das
pfarrhaus und die kirche nieder wir
wissen nicht ob anna maria diese
nachricht vernimmt auch nicht wie sie
die langen jahre im sennhof überlebt
die anstalt ordnung schrieb für alle
insassen absolutes stillschweigen vor
briefwechsel und besucher wurden nur
vierteljährlich erlaubt das essen musste
sie in der zelle einnehmen auch arbeiten
konnte sie nur dort nähen sticken oder
spinnen für die bedürfnisse der anstalt
und das für einen lohn von 5 rappen pro
tag
bei korrekter führung bekam anna maria
pro woche zwei stunden unterricht durch
eine lehrerin und durfte eine halbe
stunde pro tag im hof im kreis spazieren
der strafvollzug ist unvorstellbar hart
wie der damalige zieht und zwar
insbesondere frauen das dank man sich
habe ich es gar nicht so aber trauer
will sie das alter kriminell werden
sind entsprechend auch im strafvollzug
benachteiligt wenn sie einzeln
untergebracht werden will sie will scusi
vollzugsform gar nicht gibt will es
arbeitsmöglichkeiten nicht im gleichen
ausmaß gibt und bitte anna maria und das
völlig ich das völlig offensichtlich
dass sie statt keine muße geschaffen
haben diese zahlen schaffen sie hat die
ganze ausstattung sie hat sich im
prinzip isolationshaft
das wird man hört immer so machen
frauen strafvollzug um einiges humaner
als in der zeit vor der maria
nach 20 jahren haft kehrt anna maria
heim nach rabius der grosse rat hatte
ihr fünf jahre erlassen dies gegen die
stimmen der abgeordneten aus dem bündner
oberland die auf das angebliche
rechtsempfinden des volkes pforten
[Musik]
anna-maria wohnt wieder in ihrem
elternhaus sie lebt und arbeitet mit
ihrer schwester ihrem schwager und ihren
nachkommen
mario schlag küste hat als kind mit ihr
zusammen gelebt sie bewohnt heute das
zimmer das einst ihre großtante
anna-maria bewohnte
[Musik]
christian mann war neun jahre alt als
anna maria starb
erhält china
so wie einst anna-maria die das
federvieh mit hingabe hätte
damit die sich so
wenig sie wenn sie noch lange nicht
genug
es braucht den
rosinen oder schokolade darüber dass das
thema missbrauch sich wahnsinniger
alitalia bis jetzt eigentlich nicht
schon
irgendwie böses wort oscar alanya
beendete schock sei tisch immer
stillschweigend und klarheit kann ja so
wenig erinnern dass sie hebt
anna-maria verlässt nur selten das haus
sie bietet viel strikt und nett
ich sehe oder maria vor mir wie sie
unten auf der bank sind sie trägt ein
kopftuch einen rock aus schwerem stoff
und eine schürze sie hält den kopf
gesenkt und raucht pfeife wenn sie uns
kinder kommen dann haben sie die pfeife
aus dem mund und legte sie in die tasche
wir hatten angst dass der rock brennen
könnte
je weniger die leute anna maria kennen
umso furchterregende erscheint sie ihnen
wer sie jedoch kennt mag sie gut
sie verkaufte die eier im laden und wir
freuten uns wir wussten genau wenn sie
zurückkommt bringt sie uns karamell oder
sonst was zum naschen mit wir warteten
oft vor ihrem haus weil wir wussten
heute gibt's etwas da musste dabei sein
für ein butterbrot gehen wir weit damals
und für einen apfel noch weiter
die kinder flohen und riefen die
mörderin kommt eine frau die ihren mann
umgebracht hatte und 20 jahre im
gefängnis war das machte schon eindruck
und einfach als kinderquiz beruhen wieso
die man den gesichtern dort passiert und
böse helden vor dem nie erzählt weil sie
einfach schön dass sie selber blick
scheint das mehr einfache soll tante der
familie hängt
anna-maria geht oft in die kirche und
beichtet alle zwei wochen ihre sünden
nach der beichte besucht sie den
friedhof sie gilt als fromm und wortkarg
als frau mit strengem blick und einer
kräftigen stimme
sie haben sie recht behandelt
wenn sie ihre strafe verbüßt haben muss
man es dabei belassen sagte mein vater
führte ein zurückgezogenes leben
sie hatte keine lust mehr auf einen mann
am 14 september 1948 stirbt anna maria
nach kurzem unwohlsein und versehen mit
den sakramenten so die todesanzeige
[Musik]
das war eine schöne beerdigung alles in
ordnung
die tat war tabu als sie aus dem
gefängnis zurück kam war das erledigt
sie hatte ja ihre strafe verbüßt und
musste sich nicht schämen obwohl sie
ging immer gebückt
anna-maria wurde 84 jahre alt
sie hinterließ einen sohn und vier enkel
[Musik]